don't do that stop
doing it
what happened
it's all right we'll fix it Oscar
nominated director Darren Aronofsky is
best known for a psychological dramas
like 2017's mother and he's been busy
over the last few years producing a
documentary on climate change a reality
TV series with Chris Hemsworth a Netflix
Thriller starring Eddie Redmayne and
Jessica Chastain and now a feature film
giving Brendan Frazier The Comeback role
of his career if that wasn't enough he's
also co-written a novel mirroring The
Adventures of his youth we caught up
with Aronofsky at the scene of his
sci-fi pre-teen Adventure
when it comes to Coney Island there may
be no bigger Hometown fan than director
Darren Aronofsky is it like you remember
or is it changed yeah well it's changed
a lot but I've been coming here non-stop
since um you know my whole life I've
never stopped coming
Brooklyn's working class Beach town has
even made a few cameos in his favorite
films like 2000's Requiem for a Dream
look there's the parachute jump I know
there's a parachute jump wow and it's
prominently
first yes it's a main part of the climax
of the book that book monster Club is
aronofsky's all-in shout out to the
Boardwalk amusement park it follows a
band of Middle School Misfits battling
cartoon drawings that have mysteriously
come to life it was actually a
screenplay that never got made and a
writer friend of mine a guy who writes
science fiction books was like why don't
you turn it into a young adult novel and
it was actually a great experience
because in movies there's always show
don't tell and then we would get to a
part where we like oh how are we going
to show this and then we realize oh
the character can just think it and it
was so liberating to be able to get into
the inner monologue of a character's
mind and just move a story forward in
that way also we didn't have to worry
about budgets so suddenly the action
adventure sequence at Coney Island just
the budget went right through the roof
oronovsky is no stranger to big budget
films but he's found
success in small in smart independent
movies that tell intense sometimes
disturbing stories Through The Eyes of
Unforgettable characters I'm an old
broken down piece of meat there was
2008's the wrestler Starring Mickey
Rourke attack it attack it Natalie
Portman's turn as the Black Swan two
years later
[Music]
and Russell Crowe is Noah in aronofsky's
2014 reimagining of the biblical tale it
s
latest
whale the whale made me very
uncomfortable
it also pushed me to really penetrate
through all of that discomfort do you
hurt you
a Feeling
now
people are incapable
of not caring
foreign
people are amazing Brendan Fraser plays
Charlie a severely obese teacher who
tries to reconnect with his estranged
daughter played by stranger things Sadie
sink he talks about honesty he talks
about realness is that you
I think truth is really important I
think when I work with actors
that's the only thing I can judge is is
the actor performing in front of the
camera in front of me being honest I
think it's also when choosing these
characters I try to find characters that
are different
but that are very very real
and also unexpected to me that's a
really exciting thing it's like how do
you get into the head of a ballerina how
do you get into the head of a wrestler
how do you get into the head of Charlie
this the recluse of this movie
and remind us that even though we all
have different Journeys we're actually
all very very similar in lots of ways
you're a smart person and I bet you're a
strong writer the whale first debuted
Off-Broadway in playwright Sam Hunter
then adapted it for Aronofsky for the
big screen I saw it about 10 years ago
and when it starts off there's all these
characters that are completely not like
me but by the end they feel like members
of my family I know them so well so
deeply
that they break my heart casting was
among the biggest challenges I wasn't
really that familiar with uh Brendan's
work what
[Music]
we are in serious trouble I mean I knew
the mummy I never saw George of the
Jungle
[Music]
still haven't
or Encino Man
[Music]
it was really a gut feeling I saw him in
the trailer of a low budget Brazilian
movie and he had a small part oh I got
plenty of time it's still early and it's
just sort of a light bulb went on I
could see the fire burning inside him
and then when he came in in the room I
was like look at those eyes look at that
Soul listen to that voice but it's all
in here yeah but I didn't actually know
if he could pull it off it was really a
cut
a gut and he pulled it off he pulled it
while you you know what do you think
he's getting a little Oscar buzz forget
me like the critics are going by nanas
it's a bona fide comeback for the 53
year old actor who's receiving some of
the best reviews of his career it was
clear to me he wanted to work and he it
was clear to me he wanted an opportunity
to show what he could do it was also
clear that he hadn't had that
opportunity for a very long time to
really work and I knew that not only
emotionally was playing Charlie an
extremely difficult task but technically
it was hard because it was five hours of
makeup a day which means he worked five
hours more than every single person on
the set
five hours four hours in one hour out
every day and he was in every scene so I
mean there might have been one or two
days he had off in in the in the amount
of time we shot that says something
that's a lot of work yeah random and it
paid off big time the whale premiered at
the Venice film festival and received an
astonishing six-minute standing ovation
and in London they did not stop until
Brendan left the stage so it was really
beautiful moment yeah no matter where
his career has taken him all across the
globe the one place that has sustained
him is his old neighborhood and the city
that he still calls home at some point
in my career I always tried to do a
scene in Coney Island really um it's
just very inspiring for me there's just
a lot of rude energy for me because I
grew up here and it was always a magical
place as a kid
and I'd just like to share it with the
world yeah it's almost like you're
you're giving it a second life yeah
I wish Coney Island was open when we
were there because no cold it's like he
loves the space he's like a kid in a
candy store all over again the book
everything I saw that I remember
watching the reaction that he got that
Brendan Fraser got then in Venice at
when the movie won the awards it was
just it was it was Goosebumps he almost
cried I mean it was so emotional it was
an incredible moment it's an intense
movie and it's a heck of a performance
yeah